folge 3 von tommy versus marios
abwechselnd duellieren wir uns auf
unseren kanälen und finden heraus wer
schneller sachen lernt in der letzten
folge auf seinem kanal haben wir das
gemacht und heute
wir sind heute am skatepark und werden
innerhalb von einem tag also
idealerweise einen keks erklären das
ganze sieht so aus
also ich habe schon mal autos gelten
spielt ich glaube das kriegen wir locker
in den ersten beiden folgen sind an mich
gegangen zu sagen
dieses video wird unterstützt von skill
scheer
ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt abflug
hamburg aber wir brauchen
sicherheitskleidung sonst werden uns so
was von wehtun
die boards einmal zwei baugleiche
skateboards
über twitter user jetzt sag mal was du
kannst um den kickflip zu lernen
versuchen wir als erstes einen ort zu
leeren der uli ist die basis von so
ziemlich jedem anderen trick und sollte
optimalerweise so aussehen und nicht so
[Musik]
ja nach ist das geschafft einerseits ist
ein wort hier mal kaputt zu machen aber
er hat auch leider geschafft den oli
richtig zu stehen
das heißt in der luft wirkt die bewegung
und ich bin gelernte das neue skateboard
ist jetzt zunächst gehen halt noch eine
halbe stunde stunden dauern bis es da
ist und also ich würde sagen ich nutze
die zeit mal
es werden sogar wenn dies auch getragen
würde
aha junge habe ich noch einmal pause ja
also das neue support gegönnt und kann
sagen das ist ja was ganz anderes
doch um den oli jetzt endlich wirklich
mal zu lernen haben wir uns auf youtube
ein tutorial angeschaut wie man einen
ollie denn jetzt wirklich macht so geht
nach der opposition ist das jeden fall
gelernt hat ist dass er auf dieser
kumpel sein muss mit dem rom zu fahren
ist klar
unverändert sind und dann ist auf jeden
fall der wichtige sieg der erst den kopf
zu ihnen das heißt das wort krieg zu
stellen und dann den fuß richtig
schrägen drüber zu schleichen
man strengt mit dem buch quasi gar nicht
hoch sondern schleift ihn zugesagt
[Musik]
dann wollen wir doch mal sehen was die
tutorials und das üben so gebracht hat
vor einer von uns beiden schafft jetzt
einmal ausgesehen hätte direkt zum ende
kommt
[Musik]
zur mega oder
das war auf jeden fall der beste
versucht hatte naja das board hat sich
halt in die richtung von dem hill flip
gedreht und nicht in die von den
kickflip aber darauf kommen wir später
zurück ich habe ich schon vom boden ab
eigentlich ja klar ich bin jetzt kein
profi skater und ich kann auch noch nie
so ganz ob alibi aber heute ist dass die
eigentlichen kik ruft deswegen klingt
erst mal kickte tutorial rein wie ich
aus meinem weg weil ich vielleicht einen
locken kicks mitmachen kann alle leute
diese halbwegs gehen können und wie sie
integration gesehen haben denken sie
jetzt vorab über das man heute gucken
wir uns mal ein klick mit an krieg 17 so
an real außenpolitischen angeschaut das
sieht so leicht aus als ich das gesehen
habe macht so einmal dieses bayern dann
halt nicht gerade sondern nach vorne und
plätze machen club ist sieht so leicht
aus
es wird das heißt ich finde das sieht so
krass aus mit der promotion
ich ziehe mir auch immer öfter einmal
das wort hier so nicht schienbeine rein
das tut so weh das dritte 2009 vergeben
ich freue mich ganz besonders ich halte
meine füße dann wieder einfach meine
leute meine haut
das 19 die socken gemacht
doch ich muss halt rein stecken wenn es
weitergeht so lustig hier wirklich
[Musik]
so wäre ich keinen oder zu hause thomas
aber wenn du nicht mehr spürst ist nicht
gut
ok
dass sie noch bewegen kann
ja weil sammeln mal vielleicht auspacken
und angucken
die oberhand
was soll ich sagen
scheinbar kann man sich beim skateboard
nicht nur die knie ellenbogen handgelenk
oder den kopf verletzten wo dann die
schoner geholfen hätten sondern man kann
auch mit dem knöchel umknicken und zwar
so dass ich heute kurz bevor dieses
video online geht was zwei wochen später
immer noch schmerzen
mein fuß ist leider macht nix passen ist
keiner von uns hat irgendwie richtig
hinbekommen die wasser viel höher am
ende hat sich schon aber ich bin ja
offensichtlich nicht gelandet wurde
bisher mittlerweile auch schon 16.000
mal sogar eingedämmt wird kommen sowohl
aus da heute gibt es keinen punkt heute
gibt es keinen punkt und wird auf jeden
fall das geld noch gehalten und auch die
schoner und haben noch mal ein eigenes
ganzes video zu machen indem ich
innerhalb von einer woche dann richtig
zu lernen und auch mehrere sachen damit
sagen sehen uns bald folgen wieder
aufsagen kann alter und zwar morgen am
sonntag wo wir lernen wie man möglichst
lange die luft anhält auch wenn so was
meistens länger als einen tag dauert
liebe ich es mir ständig neue skills
beizubringen weil es gilt dem heutigen
sponsor könnte ja fast alles lernen in
tausenden klassen zur produktivität film
und viele mehr auf anfänger niveau und
für profis mit das wichtigste für
youtube und für film aber auch für
unternehmen ist es mitreißende
geschichten zu erzählen um menschen zu
bewegen genau das lernt in der kasse
powerful storytelling today strategies
for crafting great content die ersten
1000 meiner zuschauer erhalten kostenlos
eine probe der premium-mitgliedschaft es
kommen immer neue klassen dazu um sich
selbst auf das nächste level zu
befördern und mit einem jährlichen
abokosten skills ja nur acht euro pro
monat
link in der beschreibung wenn ihr mich
auf dieser reise begleiten dann
abonniert können diesen kanal und dann
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder alles
gut
[Musik]